produced in partnership with activision
[Music]
welcome to your guided tour of black out
a new way to experience call of duty and
the legendary franchises first entry
into the battle royale arena blackout is
unlike anything franchise fans have
experienced before
with over 80 players battling it out
across the largest map and Call of Duty
history blackout isn't about chill death
ratios capturing objectives or endless
response blackout is about survival
improvise adapt overcome and when the
safe zone collapses be the last man
woman or teen standing to win glory
honor and the game
[Music]
whether you play solo in a duo or on a
squad of four each black out round
begins the same helicopters drop you and
your competitors onto the map allowing
you to wingsuit to the drop zone of your
choosing and you'll have plenty of
locations to choose from the blackout
map is massive covering an array of
terrains buildings and even fan-favorite
maps from past black ops titles
including nuketown firing range and
construction site choose your DZ
carefully major landmarks may offer a
better selection of weapons and items to
loot but they tend to draw the biggest
crowds smaller structures will have a
lower density of weapons and items but
can keep you out of harm's way in those
tense early minutes of a round no matter
where you land keep in mind that nowhere
is safe for long over time the maps safe
zone constricts making areas outside at
hazardous to the unwary player if you're
caught in the blue prepare to take
steady damage that stacks the smaller
the safe zone gets
what would a Call of Duty game be
without a full-on arsenal of
customizable weapons and attachments
blackout gives you the freedom to kit
yourself out according to your play
style pistols shotguns and submachine
guns are great for close-range combat
assault rifles and DM arms are versatile
powerful and excellent for medium to
long range targets sniper rifles can
one-shot an enemy at long range and when
equipped with the right optics can even
be lethal from extreme distances
whatever your weapon of choice you can
enhance almost any gun with attachments
from scopes of varying magnifications to
four grips and stocks to boost your
accuracy to special magazines to
increase ammo count or reload speed oh
it doesn't end there
blackout boasts a panoply of gear perks
and deployables to round out your kits
armor will dampen the damage you take
giving you the second or third or fourth
chance you need to survive and your
wingsuit is always on standby to
hightail it out of a sticky situation
special equipment like bulletproof
barricades and razor wire can fortify
your position and a recon car can scout
locations from a safe distance
Kirk's a staple of Call of Duty make
their way into blackout in the form of
consumable items that boost your
character stats perks can do anything
from making you more resilient to damage
to giving you added speed and mobility
to outmaneuver your opponents
whoever said getting there is half the
fun probably had blackout in mind a host
of air land and sea vehicles lie
scattered around the map just waiting to
take you everywhere you want to be that
said a rubbing a TV or whirring
helicopter can make you more than a
little conspicuous if you're looking for
the best gear in the game
keep your eyes peeled for aerial supply
drops and special zombie loot crate's
supply drops can draw a crowd but with
great risk comes great rewards so far we
focus on the solo blackout experience
going solo gear will be plentiful but
every player on the map is an enemy and
once you're down you're out but you
don't have to go it alone in duo's your
chances of survival double you can share
equipment revive a down team member and
maintain a better sense of battlefield
awareness watts add more firepower to
your team as well as the potential for
mixing upload outs and rolls across your
grip you and your squad can get tactical
about positioning covering fire
convergence points and even the
strategic use of vehicles like duo's
quads can share equipment and revive
down members of the quad in fact your
team isn't out of the game until all
four members are eliminated
[Music]
whether you're a seasoned vet or an
eager rookie black out gives you call of
duty like you've never experienced
before deployed loot and survived and
with a little luck you could be the last
one standing
[Music]
black out is available now and call a
duty black ops 4